by the grace of Allah subhanahu wa taala
the response has been overwhelming to
say the very least alhamdulillah we've
had social media personalities and
respected Scholars sh from many parts of
the Muslim world promoting the cause we
have raised almost 1.4 million
alhamdulillah and we haven't been
sitting idy waiting to hit our Target of
2 million we have fully purchased four
properties in London
transferred their ownership to the W
after the help of Allah subhanahu wa
tala none of this would be possible
without your support so we thank you
once again this is our update to
yourselves we encourage you to stay
tuned for more updates now that the work
alhamdulillah is truly underway Alum
brothers and sisters and dear friends as
you guys may know Candace Owens was
working for Ben Shapiro and the daily
why or whatever it's called for that
matter she left that alhamdulillah you
know we supported her and you know we
gave her the credit where it's Dre for
her uh for her speaking about the truth
however it seems like Candace Owens is
um actually under a great propaganda
herself you know at the end of the day
you know she's fallen for the massive
propaganda of the war on terror and
after the fall of the Syrian regime this
buta this criminal this pharaoh of our
time Bashar al-assad may Allah subh
destroy him for the for the atrocities
that he's done uh so to me anybody
that's supporting Gaza and Palestine and
at the same breath for whatever reason
it may be is not consistent and not
condemning what bash has done to the
Muslims I mean I'm just I really beg the
question of you know please and what
kind of thinking do you have yes he's
done same if not worse in Syria but
anyway that's different topic for a
different time yeah aldah may Allah
destroy him and his father in the
Hellfire if he doesn't repent now here's
what kace Owens had to say yeah so after
the Takeover um you know because this
this shows you the left and fall here is
a screenshot of canice owens's um
Twitter X she says Christians are about
to be Mass slaughtered not just
Slaughter said Mass Slaughter about to
happen pray for Syria okay so obviously
Brother D had to put in a place and said
um absolute rubbish just stop it's
embarrassing okay um someone wrote as a
Syrian Christian I can tell you this is
false and many Christians and many
Syrian Christians are celebrating then
why are and then somebody goes then why
are they celebrating uh somebody goes
typical knee jerk misinformation
designed to point Muslims and Islam as
barbaric and this is exactly what it's
about so the funny thing is here is that
we have many testimonies throughout
history and not only that here is a
video of Christians in front of the
church celebrating the fall of Assad and
not only that many of these Christian
militias were also fighting hand with
hand with the rebels so here's the video
Let's watch ourselves in
[Applause]
[Music]
so guys you saw that for yourself but I
just want to go and point out some facts
now okay I doal with facts not emotions
okay so the first the trey of Jerusalem
that was given by the Muslims to the
Christians and Jews what did it say this
is the protection which the servant of
Allah Amir grants the people of
Palestine and they were Christians and
Muslims Jews and Christians there thus
protection is for their lives property
Church their cross for the healthy and
the sick and for all all their
co-religionist in this way that their
churches shall not be turned into
dwelling houses nor will they be pulled
down and nor any injur will be done to
them or to their enclosures nor to their
cross and nor will anything be deducted
from their wealth no restriction shall
be made regard regarding their religious
ceremonies no Jew will be allowed to
stay along with them this this was a
request by the Christians by the way
this CIA Jews will be staying with them
okay that was by the request of the
Christians yeah they were hostile
towards the Jews it uh it could um it
should be incumbent upon the people of
Palestine that they will pay the jizya
the capitation uh tax like other cities
they must expel the Greeks etc etc etc
yeah so this is one thing there is the
Treaty of the Islamic in Islamic Spain
similar things Subhan Allah okay and not
only that let's look at non-muslim
testimonies both Jews and Christians who
lived under Islamic rule let's see how
they was because Candace you've never
lived under Islamic rule you've been
fully uh you know under this propaganda
that Islam and terrorism and Muslims are
apparently have to no the Christians and
the Jews are close to us so especially
when it so here is in Constantinople in
those days the Orthodox residing in
Constantinople was afraid of the
Catholic pressure against them if I'm
not mistaken you're a Catholic yeah you
guys persecuted a lot of other
denominations of Christians yourselves
there were those who saw Ottomans as a
savior because the Empire granted
religious freedom to Christians
everywhere it conquered prime minister
Grand Duke Locus notus one said I would
rather see a Turkish turban in the midst
of the city Constantinople than the
Latin um Mitra in the year 1492 when
60,000 Jews were expelled from Spain by
Ferdinand and Isabel Christians who were
mascarin Muslims and Jews for that
matter they immigrated to Istanbul to
live under ottoman rule samien we want
to see the world send the world a
message that we have been living here
peacefully for centuries while other
Jewish communities have suffered in Many
Lands of Europe neest and Joe John B pan
in the year 690 expressed fascinating
sentiments regarding the rain of muaah a
Muslim yes the peace throughout the
world was such that we have never heard
neither from our fathers or from our
grandparents or seen that they had ever
been like it okay Bernard the wise a
pilgrim monk visited Egypt and Palestine
in the reign of Al okay he stated that
the Christians and the pagans he used to
call the pagans Muslims yeah have this
kind of peace between them that if I was
to go on a journey and on the way my
Camelo donkey was to die okay and I was
Abed with all my goods and I left all my
goods without any guardian and gone and
gone into the city for another pack of
animal when I came back I would I would
find all my property intact such was the
peace with the Christians and the
Muslims yes in the in 8
8669 patriarch theodosis of Jerusalem
wrote the sarasin they were not they
called them the SAR Muslims show us
great Goodwill they allow us to build
our churches and to observe our own
Customs without hindrance yes Mass uh
Slaughter yeah okay there we go Jews
felt equally safe in Jerusalem as
confirmed by a 9th century Jewish Source
sa Pon Torah the people in whose hands
is the temple in today's namely the
Muslims have made it into a choice
excellent and honorable place of worship
they say let us worship the one true uh
God in heaven and earth to whom the
creatures belong until the coming of of
um of the Messiah and on that day the
true worship will be renowned renowned
and will be acceptable before God the
let's goes on I'll just mention another
one okay Michael the Elder the Jacobite
Patra of Antioch in the 12th century
wrote in the favor of Muslims after
after condemning the tyranny of
Christian bisan ties for when the city
is subdued to the Arabs they assigned to
each denomination the churches which
they found in it to be in the possession
of and at that time the great church of
um MSA and that of haran had been taken
away from us by the byzantines
nevertheless it was no slight Advantage
for us to be delivered from the cruelty
of the Romans I I the byzantines their
wickedness their rough and cruel Zeal
against us and to find ourselves at
peace and I will end on this not the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him made
it very categorically clear the prophet
peace be upon him had taught his
companions well and had warned them to
be careful with regards to the rights of
humans as well as animals Abu Bakr the
first khif instructed the muslim's Army
by saying I advise you to advise you 10
things do not kill women do not kill
children or any aged infant infam person
do not show do not uh cut down fruit
bearing trees do not destroy an
inhabited Place do not Slaughter sheep
or camels except for food do not harm
bees and do not scatter them do not
steal from the booty and do not be
cowardly and this is the teachings of
the Prophet Muhammad peace be upon him
you might find this Behavior this
attitude that you're really scared of of
Mass Slaughter of Christians by the
Zionist regime by them not by the
Muslims they are not our teachers okay
that's why let's make it very clear the
prophet PE upon him said any Christian
or Jew who's under the protection of
Muslims who pays J and lives on Muslim
lands the prophet PE said he will not
smell the fragrance of paradise anyone
that harms a themi under the protection
of Muslims so can this you are under
some kind of delusion or I don't know
what kind of me TV you've been watching
you talk about the Zionist regime and
try to expose them but when it comes to
yourself you're under
what kind of brainwashing is this oh
pray for the Muslims to Sy they're going
to get Mass slaughtered what utter
nonsense and rubbish history speaks for
itself for those who lived under Islamic
rule that's all I have to say brother
sisters till next time